- Un prince en exil préoccupé
par la situation en Iran.
À 56 ans, Reza Pahlavi,
réclame plus de pressions
de la communauté internationale
pour mettre fin au régime
des mollahs.
REZA PAHLAVI,
fils aîné du shah d'Iran
- C'est que vous devez avoir
dans votre calcul l'anticipation
que ce régime pourrait tomber
à chaque moment. Est-ce que
nous avons suffisamment
travaillé sur l'alternative?
- Car selon lui, l'alternative
au régime ne va pas arriver
miraculeusement.
- C'est une question de temps,
ce n'est pas une question
de "si", mais "quand".
- Il multiplie les arguments.
- Dès que ce régime est fini,
il n'y a plus de financement
des réseaux terroristes,
il n'y a plus de Hezbollah,
il n'y a plus de Hamas,
il n'y a plus de menace
nucléaire. Tout ceci disparaît
instantanément.
(détonations)
- Le pays s'enflamme depuis
la mort de Mahsa Amini, 22 ans,
arrêtée d'abord parce que
son voile était mal ususté, puis
battue à mort selon sa famille
durant sa garde à vue à Téhéran.
Depuis, les manifestations
se multiplient. 1200 personnes
auraient été aêêtées en Iran,
des dizaines tuées depuis
le 16 septembre, dont
Hadis Najafi, 20 ans,
qui est devenue un autre
symbole  r résistance en Iran.
En Syrie, en Turquie, en Iran,
les femmes se coupent
les cheveux en signe
de solidarité.
Aujourd'hui, Justin Trudeau
annonce d'autres sanctions
contre le régime iranien.
"Nous imposerons des sanctions
contre la police des moeurs",
dit-il.
L'Occident condamne le régime,
mais, sur le terrain,
la répression continue.
- Où sont tous ces mouvements
féministes aujourd'hui
au soutien des Iraniennes?
Où sont tous ces mouvements
qui soutiennent les droits
de la communauté LGBTQ?
- 40 ans d'exil, après que
son père, le shah d'Iran,
à la tête d'une mararchie
jugée répressive, fut chassé
du pouvoir par l'ayatollah
Khomeiny, accueill
par le peuple en 1979.
Reza Pahlavi se décrit
comme un facilitateur et
ne souhaite pas un retour
de la monarchie, mais
une transition démocratique
en Iran, où il y aurait
séparation de l'Église
et de l'État.
- On est fiers...
Excusez-moi.
Ils ont trop payé
et ils en ont assez.
Donc, on fait ce qu'on peut,
tout ce qu'on peut, mais
j'ai espoir qu'ils vont réussir
et je sais qu'ils vont réuirir.
C'est une question de temps.
- Et comme il y a 40 ans,
il espère que le peup i iranien
aura le dernier mot.
Ici Azeb Wolde-Giorghis,
Radio-Canada, Washingto